bei uns jetzt im studio unser kollege
peter tiede peter du hast heute ja das
ganze direkt vorm kanzleramt von für uns
verfolgt und ein thema war auch das
impfen und es ist auch ein großes thema
für uns alle weil wir natürlich hoffen
dass so schnell es geht desto schneller
kommen wir aus diesem ständigen lock
down raus was waren da heute in deinen
augen die wichtigsten aussagen rund ums
thema impfen kurskorrektur versucht also
heute vor gebaut und hat hinter dann auf
twitter nachgezogen er versucht uns
darauf einzustellen dass es empfindlich
ganz so zügig los geht wie ursprünglich
von ihm angekündigt und das wohl nicht
so viele impfdosen zum anfang da sein
werden gleich im januar wie von ihm
angekündigt jetzt noch vor wenigen tagen
zwar schlechter nachrichten also ein ja
ich eigentlich zwei sehr schlechte
nachrichten aber im wesentlichen hat
sich gern entspannt auch nur selbst
korrigiert wenn wir einmal gucken würden
wir haben in dieser woche bei bild einem
zeitstrahl gemacht also wann wird wer
geimpft mit zahlen wie viele leute sind
im ersten quartal dran und im zweiten
quartal waren sind welche gruppen durch
da haben wir schon andere zahlen benutzt
als der gesundheitsminister selbst weil
wir mit experten vorher gesprochen haben
und die uns andere zahlen gesagt die
gesagt vorsichtig bei den zahlen die aus
dem gesundheitsministerium kommen die
sind noch zu hoch es gibt weniger
eins davon ist zum beispiel es gibt
produktionsprobleme bei biontech bei und
text die deutsche firma aus mainz die
mit dem ersten impfstoff also der dem
wir jetzt in den usa sind der in
großbritannien schon verimpft wird und
die haben offensichtlich so viel wie wir
wissen
in belgien in einer produktionsstraße
erhebliche probleme also sie kriegen da
nicht eine stabile qualität hin
und deswegen kommt zunächst weniger bei
allem was im bild stand oft bild.de
stand und was er hier beim btv dann auch
gezeigt haben waren schon die neuen
zahlen eingerechnet aber jens spahn
reagiert auch darauf dass zunehmend
unmut hoch kommt weil woanders gibt es
den impfstoff schon und bei uns noch
nicht ein deutscher im stoff der nicht
zuerst bei uns geben von ersten halben
welt und wir kriegen ihn irgendwo mal
jahre sollen ganze viertel für die für
unsere zuschauer wie kann man das
erklären also usa großbritannien israel
bahrain saudi arabien ich glaube es gibt
noch weitere jetzt auch da gibt es das
schon warum und warum ich bei uns zwei
verschiedene zulassungs arten dass eine
notfall zulassung fti in den usa und die
zulassungsbehörden in großbritannien
danach richten sich zum beispiel auch
staaten wie zum beispiel mit israel
notfall zulassung bei der eu bei der ema
wird eine bedingte zulassung bei
beantragte unterschied liegt
offensichtlich in der haftung wenn du
eine notfall zulassung als staat machst
dann
aber erstmal bei dem ganzen geld was wir
jetzt hier gerade raushauen also oder
finanzminister sitzt und wieder sagt ja
wir übernehmen alles auch für die
geschäfte und so weiter wie so sagt man
dann nicht ist uns doch scheißegal
natürlich machen wir jetzt auch so den
notfall zulassung gute frage die antwort
kennt der bundesgesundheitsminister weil
rein theoretisch hat in die möglichkeit
nach einer mit einer verordnung zur
medizinischen versorgung da gibt es ganz
komplizierten begriff und da gibt's auch
ein paragraph für weil eigentlich ist
das medikament von bayer und technischen
durchgeprüft vom paul ehrlich institut
in deutschland das ist bei uns die
eigentliche zulassungsbehörde die haben
das begleitet bei bei und die haben die
kennen die gesamten prozesse kennen alle
daten alle zahlen alles durchgekommen
die eu auch daran die berichtserstattung
länder die gibt länder die sind
zuständig die haben die prüfung fertig
daten liegen vor eigentlich hätte der
besuch des google
bundesgesundheitsminister von zwei drei
wochen sagen können okay daten da ich
sage kraft meine wassersuppe verordnung
wir lassen das ding zu aber du kennst du
doch viele was ist ein gefühl waren lag
dass man will nicht europäisch wirken
und man hat angst davor dass wenn das
große deutschland sagt wir stellen vor
dann geht sie das schlechte laune in der
eu mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren